So let's look at this
matrix a little bit more.
This is a matrix,
the size here is m x n.
That's because we have m rows from 1,
2, 3 all the way going up to m.
And we have n columns.
So if you look at 1 2
all the way up to n.
The first row we know corresponds
to the user 1 that we have.
Similarly, the second row is going to
correspond to user 2, user 3, and
the last one is going to be for user m.
Similarly if we look at the columns,
remember these were for objects or
resources.
So this is for Object 1, this is for
Object 2, and all the way to Object n.
So we are talking about ACM U, O.
So that's going to be
some entry like this.
So if you take a look at it,
this is are ACM 3,
because it's user 3 that we
are talking about and object 2.
So this entry A32,
which is basically going to describe
how user three, or U3,
is allowed to access object O2.
If it happens to a file, it could
be read access or write access or
execute access.
Things like that.
So this is what we just discussed for
the case where there m users, n objects.
So this is an m by n matrix,
a row here corresponds to user,
a column here responds to object.
So again if you focus on a particular
entry in this one, remember,
this is what axis does user 3 have for
object 3, A33 is.
So this is going to be
a subset of the axis right.
How this object can be accessed.
Object O3 for example here,
user 3 we have here.
So depending on what kind of object
this is, so we've been talking about
file objects that contain data
which can be read or written, so.
The access rights for
a file may be read write and execute.
So this can be some subset.
This could be nothing.
That means user 3 could not
access object O3 in any way.
If it just has read then we
know that reads are allowed.
User 3 cannot write or
execute a file that is object 3.
If it read write execute then of course
user 3 is allowed to read or write or
execute this file that
corresponds to object O3.